hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta emisión nos
acompaña diego gonzález él es médico
veterinario colombiano pero hace ya 12
años comenzó una carrera como modelo que
los llevó a viajar por todo el mundo y
tras haber estado muchísimas veces por
trabajo en ucrania finalmente en el año
2019 se instaló en ese país y cuando
estalló la guerra estaba viviendo en la
ciudad de luzcan noroeste del territorio
ucraniano pocos días atrás logró salir
del país juntos familia y se encuentran
en varsovia la capital de polonia diego
gonzález muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en france 24
santiago
no gracias el gusto es nuestro digo
bueno el 24 de febrero cuando esta sola
garra vos y tu familia le contamos a la
audiencia que tienes una esposa que es
ucraniana y tienen dos hijos se
despertaron con los bombardeos a poca
distancia de su apartamento contanos
cómo volvió la familia a aquel momento
particularmente tus niños
bueno muy difícil alas
tim hoy
45 de la mañana nos despertó el zumbido
de el avión creo que un avión y tres
bombazos en el aeropuerto militar de
luxe es a las afueras de la ciudad pero
uno pues no es una ciudad pequeña no
entonces menos de cinco kilómetros las
ventanas las puertas las ymbro nea
mi hijo mayor matías se despertó y
pues qué está pasando no
tranquilo tranquilo no va a pasar nada
nosotros somos una familia creyente el
señor está con nosotros sus ángeles
están alrededor nuestro así que
tranquilo él se levantó y se sentó en su
escritorio le gusta mucho dibujar
y son dibujitos
pues en la inocencia de un niño no
escribió con el pulso la bandera de
ucrania y puso en ucrania no estamos en
guerra resiste un cráneo
salimos esta mañana nos fuimos a buscar
a la mamá de mi esposa mi suegra y claro
al salir del apartamento a 6 de la
mañana de ver el caos en la ciudad la
gente corriendo a sacar su dinero de los
cajeros automáticos a comprar comida en
los supermercados y las filas en las
bombas de servicio en las estaciones de
servicio para los coches con combustible
el caos pues el bebé no entiende no pero
matías que tiene 7 años al ver esto pues
es complicado de manejar y más para uno
no padre no tratar de explicarle que no
que no porque nosotros seamos buenas
personas el resto de la gente es igual y
mucho menos los que están en el poder no
entonces
pues llegamos a la casa al apartamento
de mi suegra también ver a una señora
que ha tenido que vivir porque los
ucranianos han tenido que vivir cosas
muy duras a través de su historia
y ver en la cara de ella el dolor de
webb otra vez tenemos que pasar por lo
mismo no
estuvimos ese día todo ese día en luz y
por la noche por informaciones de gente
cercana a la familia estaba en el
ejército bien puestos gubernamentales
nos dijeron si ustedes tienen la
oportunidad de salir de la ciudad
háganlo cuanto antes entonces tuvimos en
la tarde y abastecimos el carro lo
llenamos de combustible y en la noche
cuando ya está un poco más tranquilas la
vida las cosas de la ciudad ahí dios de
hicieron bueno abandonar la ciudad y se
fueron hacia una aldea verdad donde
encontraron un refugio y además no era
cualquier refugio ni cualquier casa digo
porque estamos hablando de la misma casa
en la que bueno en la que vos y tu
familia se refugiaron de la invasión
ucraniano buscando paz tranquilidad esa
misma casa había sido utilizada por los
abuelos de tu esposa para refugiarse
durante la segunda guerra mundial como
continuó así la vida digo
bueno como correcto si es es una aldea
no son la rural ucrania profunda está
entre el club y más o menos a unos 100
km del bosque
pues entonces es un sector campesino de
siembra de animales
pues es un lugar muy tranquilo en
comparación con la ciudad allá no se
escuchan las sirenas de de ataque
antiaéreo de posible ataque aéreo
entonces después llegamos allí esa casa
un documento era la casa de los abuelos
de mi esposa y ellos
se escondieron durante la cual la
persecución de los últimos años
y la persecución bolchevique y la
segunda y la segunda guerra mundial
ellos esperaron ahí ya ahora es la casa
de la prima de mi esposa pero ellos
obviamente nos dijeron bien hasta para
acá aquí y si hay espacio para cuatro
hay espacio para ocho entonces llegamos
ahí estuvimos ahí
una semana larga
y pues otra otra otra historia no hayan
o no se escuchaban ni la sirena en
ningún bar de o ni nada entonces como
que nos calmamos un poco y
empezamos a pensar que hacernos y si
seguir ahí esperando tratar de salir de
polonia pero a salir a polonia pero en
ese momento no era una opción no porque
las
fronteras se colapsaron en los primeros
días
finalmente decidieron escapar no cómo
fue ese proceso para llegar hasta
polonia
bueno como vimos que él estaba como
tranquilo dijimos devolvamos salud el
sistema nuestras maletas y tengamos las
listas por si nos devolvemos agua quema
que es el nombre de la aldea o si
intentamos tomar carretera e irnos a la
ala en plan frontera más cercana que es
ya godín
entonces llegamos ese sábado a luz
volvimos a ese sábado y duramos domingo
lunes martes miércoles y dijimos no pues
está tranquilo había nada algunas veces
que sonaba la alarma la sirena pero
entonces esa noche del viernes a la
madrugada otra vez bombardeo y estaba en
silla con mucho mucho más cerca yo
alcancé a hacer un vídeo al primer
bombardeo fueron tres al primero me
asomé por la ventana era en las 5 de la
mañana todavía está oscuro pero de la
magnitud de la explosión se hizo de día
yo dije no no pues nos tenemos que ir de
aquí yo salimos rápido y si hay incluso
un vídeo y se ha alcanzado a ver la nube
parecía una nube normal pero no era el
humo de la explosión detrás de tres
edificios de donde yo estaba
les dijimos nos vamos nos vamos fuimos a
la estación de bus y como pudimos
encontramos piquetes para los tres y
tomamos rumbo
a varsovia
a la frontera con iago no
había perdón dio una cierta sensación de
que no iba a llegarse a este punto tan
álgido del conflicto una sensación de
que quizás iba a mermar o que no iba a
ocurrir lo que finalmente ocurrió
pues habíamos estado avisados desde
mucho antes nos avisó que los medios
había necesitado que inminente inminente
inminente invasión y pues ya estaba como
el cuento de hoy no fío mañana así hoy
invada mañana así y así llevamos yo yo
yo tenía en mi corazón no va a pasar
nada no pasar nada no pasar nada una
sorpresa del 24 pero igual continuaba
con ello no esto va a calmarse
pero ya el tener que
lo que le comentaba uno no valora las
cosas hasta que no las tiene uno no sabe
el
lo increíble que es poder dormir en paz
hasta cuando ya no lo tiene esa noche la
de la última noche con las sirenas cada
media hora la zozobra de no saber si con
esa sirena va a haber un ataque o si nos
iban a caer bombas donde van a caer muy
difícil y más aún explicárselo a un niño
no y que el niño y que los niños vivan
esto entonces dijimos no
no nos vamos aún con el corazón roto no
porque como dice mi esposa no me
preguntes por mi familia cómo está
porque ahora mi familia son 44 millones
de ucrania y es así la familia de mi
esposa quedó adentro y pues todos mis
amigos la gente que conocimos están
adentro entonces uno con que está un
poco más tranquilo pero con el dolor de
esta gente sigue allá y esto se va a
poner aún más difícil y estás en
contacto con ellos que información que
se al respecto como están
pues
es muy difícil no están bien porque todo
el mundo siempre dice no estamos bien
pero un avión de estado haya uno sabe
que dice uno dice que está bien pero la
procesión va por dentro y la angustia y
la zozobra va y usted sabe que el estrés
es una
cosa que enferma a cualquiera el
producto lo enferma por por donde sea
entonces aunque digan que están bien yo
estuve allá y también le decía a mi
familia estamos bien estamos bien pero
pero a qué precio
digo bueno dentro de todo aquí lo error
en polonia te encontraste no con gestos
de enorme humanidad verdad
eso me ha llamado muchísimo la atención
la parte humana de los polacos llegar a
la frontera y ese desborde de de
sentirse uno pudiéramos estar en el
puesto de ustedes vamos a hacer lo
posible porque esta situación tan
difícil sea lo menos difícil en la
medida de nuestras posibilidades
una vez pasamos al otro lado la cantidad
de voluntarios
ofreciendo comida ofreciendo mantas para
los niños juguetes a mi esposa le dieron
un coche porque nosotros tenemos un niño
de 2 años es muy difícil que el camine
al ritmo nuestro no y nosotros decimos
cómo nos vamos con un coche si apenas
pudimos [__] lo básico de ropa y cargar
dos maletas y vámonos entonces ver esa
parte humana de los de los polacos
nuevos wheel
y me imagino que no ha sido muy
importante sobre todo luego haber dejado
atrás las imágenes que narraba bueno ya
estás en polonia en un contexto de un
poco más tranquilidad no como son los
días se están evaluando cómo continuarán
sus vidas y dónde hacerlo
claro porque es básicamente volver a
empezar no
aunque por nuestro trabajo nosotros
sabemos lo que es tener nuestra casa en
dos maletas de 30 kilos y de contrato en
contrato ir volando de ciudad a ciudad
pues en este contexto es un poco más
complicado por lo que tenemos que
empezar de cero totalmente a vamos a ver
si seguimos con nuestro lo que veníamos
antes trabajando o si nos tocará empezar
a buscar pues alguna otra opción
afortunadamente la embajada de colombia
en polonia ha estado
fenomenal el acompañamiento la ayuda el
apoyo ha sido increíble nos recogieron
en la estación de buses nos consiguieron
un hospedaje
unos bonos de herb y envie para una
estadía larga
entonces en estos días vamos a estar
evaluando polonia va a dar unas ayudas
había la opción de volver a colombia
pero para mí no era una opción porque
pues hace 12 años salí porque no tuve
las opciones en colombiano imposible
ahora llegar con tres bocas más a donde
llegar a hacer que a engrosar las cifras
de desempleados entonces con el dolor
del alma de querer que mis papás
conozcan a sus nietos pero en este
contexto en estas circunstancias no
podría volver
entonces vamos a ver esto no perdón
diego se nos acabó el tiempo muchísimas
gracias por estos minutos con france24
sido un placer dialogar contigo
muchas gracias por escuchar la historia
no gracias a ti una vez más a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
que sigan informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france mit y
cuatro.com
[Música]